you
if you were a kid in the late 90s you
played Goldeneye 64 it didn't matter if
you were a nerd or a cool kid if you
were a nerd at school in the cool kids
like do you play Goldeneye play Nintendo
64 no matter what they said they were at
home going oh my cool
Goldeneye 64 is one of the best
first-person shooters ever made and in
fact it is also the best in my opinion
anyway film to video game adaptation
because normally those are awful
seriously there are only a few films of
video game adaptations that are actually
good I can think of Goldeneye and Spider
Man 2 and not too many more the game
took locations in the movie and scenes
in the movie and expanded upon them
greatly and added a few extra things too
but really what is so good here in my
opinion the best part of Goldeneye 64 is
the replay value you can play these
lands over and over and over and they
don't get boring it's so strange there
are three difficulty settings which is
really cool because each difficulty
comes with the possibility of gaining a
new secret code of some kind in which
you can do like paintball mode or donkey
kong mode each difficulty as you beat
the game you get an extra new land so it
makes you want to just beat the whole
game all the way up to double O agent
which is actually extremely hard
these old Symphonic game scores are
great I love the score for this game
it's so like I can actually listen to
the score as just driving or on my
computer I mean yeah I'm a nerd so I
mean yeah but still it's awesome I
remember when I got this game I remember
exactly what was going on I was in
school and I heard that the game was at
home waiting for me and I could not wait
for the day to end so I could get home
and play Goldeneye 64 and this game was
hours and hours and hours and hours of
fun and years of fun actually because I
kept going back to it and just learning
new things about it and enjoying it it's
one of my favourite games of all time a
lot of FPS games nowadays are modeled
after it games like Perfect Dark that
came after it really followed that
system
it's a rare where game so you know they
put a lot of time and effort into it if
you're still into retro games we still
play in 64 and you haven't played
Goldeneye what I mean
I'm going to try to do more video game
reviews from time to time it'll more
than likely be classic or retro game
safe from NES Super NES Sega Genesis n64
that kind of thing because that's just
how I roll
comment below in stuckman score and let
me know what's your favorite retro game
how do you feel about Goldeneye 64 let
me know what you think if you liked this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get stuck mine eyes Oh mate